IT’S 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY AND
THIS IS "THE FIVE."
>> Juan: PRESIDENT TRUMP
DECLARING A NATIONAL EMERGENCY
OVER THE CORONAVIRUS.
THERE ARE NOW MORE THAN 1600
CASES AND 41 DEATHS IN THE
UNITED STATES.
HERE’S THE PRESIDENT.
>> TO UNLEASH THE FULL POWER OF
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THIS
EFFORT TODAY I AM OFFICIALLY
DECLARING A NATIONAL EMERGENCY.
AS A RESULT OF THAT ACTION TODAY
WE ARE ANNOUNCING A NEW
PARTNERSHIP WITH PRIVATE SECTOR
TO VASTLY INCREASE AND
ACCELERATE OUR CAPACITY TO TEST
FOR THE CORONAVIRUS.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
WHO NEED A TEST CAN GET A TEST
VERY SAFELY, QUICKLY AND
CONVENIENTLY.
THE NEXT 8 WEEKS ARE CRITICAL.
WE CAN LEARN AND WE WILL TURN A
CORNER ON THIS VIRUS.
SOME OF THE DOCTORS SAY IT WILL
WASH THROUGH.
IT WILL FLOW THROUGH.
INTERESTING TERMS.
AND VERY ACCURATE.
I HAVE THINK YOU ARE GOING TO
FIND, IN A NUMBER OF WEEKS IT’S
GOING TO BE A VERY ACCURATE
TERM.
>> Juan: THE PRESIDENT’S
DECLARATION OF A NATIONAL
EMERGENCY.
A LOT OF PRESSURE COMING FROM
LOTS OF DIRECTIONS BUT DID HE
IT.
JESSE, WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF IT.
>> Jesse: NOT SO MUCH WHAT HE
SAYS.
IT’S WHAT HE DOES.
AND WHEN YOU UNLEASH $50 BILLION
THAT’S GOING TO DO A LOT.
THE MARKETS LOVED IT.
YOU KNOW, EVERYBODY WAS
CRITICIZING HIM WHEN HE SPOKE ON
WEDNESDAY, AND THE MARKETS WENT
DOWN.
AND NOW HE SPEAKS AND THE
MARKETS GO UP.
SO IT’S REALLY ABOUT ACTION MORE
THAN ANYTHING.
HE HAS UNLEASHED THE PRIVATE
SECTOR.
A LOT OF PEOPLE WERE EXPECTING
THAT WHEN YOU BRING IN ROCHE AND
GOOGLE AND RAMP UP TESTING AND
EVEN DRIVE-THRU TESTING WHICH WE
HAVE SEEN IN SOUTH KOREA AND
PEOPLE ARE VERY EXCITED ABOUT
THAT SO, IF YOU REALLY UNLOCK
THE RESOURCES WITH THE HOSPITALS
AND THE MEDICAL INDUSTRY, PEOPLE
ARE GOING TO BE FEELING A LOT
MORE CONFIDENT.
NOW, NANCY PELOSI NEEDS TO GET
HER ACT TOGETHER.
I DON’T KNOW WHAT SHE IS WAITING
FOR.
THEY NEED TO COME TOGETHER AND
GET THE TAX CUT WITH THE PAYROLL
DEAL DONE.
ALONG WITH WORKER RELIEF AND
PAID LEAVE.
THAT SHOULD HAPPEN NOW.
I DON’T KNOW WHAT’S TAKING THEM
THAT LONG AND ON MONDAY THE
MARKETS WILL RESPOND TO THAT
VERY STRONGLY.
THE PRESIDENT SAID HE’S GOING TO
GET TESTED.
THAT WAS BIG NEWS ITEM RIGHT
THERE.
AND I THINK WE WILL AWAIT HIS
RESULTS BECAUSE ALLEGEDLY HE HAS
BEEN IN CONTACT WITH PEOPLE THAT
HAVE TESTED POSITIVE.
STANDING NEXT TO THEM.
TAKING PICTURES WITH THEM.
AND IF HE TESTS NEGATIVE A MAN
OF HIS AGE IT KIND OF GIVES YOU
AN INDICATION ABOUT THE
CONTAGION ASPECT.
>> Juan: OKAY.
HOLD ON BECAUSE WE HAVE SOME
TAPE OF THAT.
>> Jesse: OKAY.
>> ARE YOU BEING SELFISH BY NOT
GETTING TESTED AND --
>> -- I DIDN’T SAY I WASN’T
GOING TO BE TESTED.
>> ARE YOU GOING TO BE.
>> MOST LIKELY, YEAH.
NOT FOR THAT REASON BUT BECAUSE
I THINK I WILL DO IT ANYWAY.
>> WILL YOU LET US KNOW THE
RESULTS.
>> WE ARE WORKING ON THAT.
WE ARE WORKING OUT A SCHEDULE.
>> Juan: WHAT DO YOU SAY,
SHANNON?
>> Shannon: I DON’T THINK HE
WILL WANT TO GET A TEST OH THE
PRESIDENT CAN GET A TEST AND NO
ONE ELSE CAN GET A TEST.
YOU KNOW SOME PEOPLE WILL GET A
TALKING TEST OH I HAD A TEST 8
DAYS AGO.
BRET BAIER POINTED OUT EARLIER
IT COULD BE A TEST THAT ROLLS
OUT WHEN THE WHOLE TESTING KIT.
LOOK I WILL BE ONE OF THE ONES
TO TAKE IT EVERYONE WILL GET THE
TEST.
MAYBE A TIE-IN THERE.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT MADE ME
REALLY SAD WAS THIS THING ABOUT
NURSING HOMES AND CAN’T GO
VISIT.
OLD PEOPLE ARE MY TRIBE AND I
LOVE IT.
I LIKE TO HANG OUT IN NURSING
HOMES.
PEOPLE NEED TO BE CHEERED UP.
>> Jesse: YOU LOVE TO HANG OUT.
>> Shannon: WE WOULD GO EVERY
SUNDAY AFTER CHURCH AND MY MOM
WOULD TAKE HER UKELELE AND I
WOULD STAND ON THE TABLE AND
SING SONGS.
>> Greg: WHY WOULD YOU TORTURE
THOSE PEOPLE.
>> THEY WERE HARD OF HEARING BUT
I THINK MY SINGING WAS OKAY.
ADOPT A NURSING HOME.
KIDS HAVE SCHOOL KIDS HAVE FREE
TIME FLOOD THE NURSING HOMES.
>> Greg: DON’T GO.
>> Shannon: NO.
>> Nicole: DON’T GO.
>> Shannon: CAN YOU SEND LETTERS
AND CARDS BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE
GOING TO BE SO LONELY THEY NEED
HUMAN CONTACT.
I SAY WE ADOPT NURSING HOMES.
>> Juan: I’M STRUCK BY WHAT
SHANNON IS TALKING ABOUT BECAUSE
ONE OF THE CONSTANT POINTS OF
CRITICISM IS THE SHORTAGE OF
TESTING.
AND, OF COURSE, THE PRESIDENT IS
NOW SAYING HE IS -- THEY ARE
MAKING AN EFFORT.
I THINK HE EVEN HAVE THE GUY
FROM WALMART THERE USE THE
PARKING LOTS FOR DRIVE-THRU
TESTING?
>> Greg: RIGHT.
>> Juan: WHAT DO YOU MAKE?
>> Greg: WHEN WE THINK ABOUT
9/11, A LOT OF THINGS THAT TOOK
PLACE ENDED UP BEING PERMANENT.
A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE STILL TAKING
OFF THEIR SHOES.
SOME THINGS YOU WANT TO BE
PERMANENT.
FOR EXAMPLE, IF THERE ARE
INNOVATIONS IN TESTING AND
TELEMEDICINE?
I WANT THOSE THINGS TO BE
PERMANENT.
I WANT TO USE A SITUATION TO
CREATE THINGS WHERE CAN YOU
DRIVE-THRU AND GET A TEST FOR
ANYTHING.
I AM REALLY PLEASANTLY SURPRISED
HOW THE MEDIA CARES ABOUT HIS
HEALTH, YOU KNOW.
FIRST THEY WANTED HIM OUT
BECAUSE HE IS INSANE.
NOW THEY WANT HIM TO REMAIN
ALIVE.
I ALSO LIKE THE FACT THAT HE
FIELDED QUESTIONS UNLIKE BERNIE
AND BIDEN.
BUT IT’S GOOD.
WHAT YOU ARE SEEING IS VERY
SIMILAR TO WHAT HAPPENED IN
WORLD WAR II.
COMPANIES JOIN TOGETHER TO FIGHT
AND IT DEMONSTRATES A LOT OF
STUFF IS GOING ON THAT IS
REALLY.
AND ONE OF THE GOOD SIGNS ABOUT
THIS IS THE NUMBER ONE COMPLAINT
THAT I NOTICED IN THE MEDIA ON
TWITTER LACK OF DIVERSITY.
SO THAT’S YOUR COMPLAINT, THINGS
ARE PRETTY GOOD IF YOU ARE MAD
THAT THEY WERE ALL THE WRONG
COLOR.
>> Jesse: WHAT ABOUT AMBASSADOR
BURKS.
SHE IS A FEMALE.
>> Greg: BUT SHE IS WHITE,
JESSE.
COME ON.
>> Jesse: BIG CONTROVERSY.
>> Greg: FORGET ABOUT THEIR
IMPRESSIVE SKILLS, YOU KNOW.
>> Juan: BOY, YOU GUYS ARE YOU
HAVE SOME PREOCCUPATION.
YOU SHOULD CHECK OUT THE SURGEON
GENERAL SOME TIME.
IS HE A MAN OF COLOR.
>> Greg: I’M TALKING ABOUT THE
PEOPLE ON TWITTER, NOT ME.
>> Juan: DR. SAPHIER, THE WHOLE
IDEA THAT THE PROBLEM COULD
CONTINUE WAS EXPRESSED BY
DR. FAUCI TODAY.
HE SAID THIS COULD BE NOT A
MATTER OF WEEKS BUT A MATTER OF
MONTHS.
AND I WAS STRUCK BY.
THIS HE SAID EIGHT WEEKS LOOKS
LIKE WHAT IS REALISTIC
PREDICTION TO HIM.
>> Nicole: I THINK ACTUALLY HE
HAS SAID SEVERAL DIFFERENT
THINGS, FOUR TO FIVE WEEKS UNTIL
THINGS START CALMING DOWN WE MAY
HIT EQUILIBRIUM I DO THINK THAT
IS REALISTIC IT.
COULD BE SHORTER THAN THAT
PROBABLY NOT.
IT COULD BE LONGER THAN THAT THE
POINT IS WE ARE TAKING THE
EFFECTIVE MEASURES TO DO WHAT WE
CAN TO CONTROL THE SPREAD AND
GET THINGS UNDER CONTROL.
THIS WAS A VERY IMPORTANT
PRESSER TODAY WENT ON MUCH
LONGER THAN I EXPECTED.
THEY TOOK A LOT OF QUESTIONS
WHICH WAS THE RIGHT THING TO DO.
TRANSPARENCY IS GOING TO HELP.
WE SAW THE STOCK MARKET RESPOND
RIGHT AWAY.
AND I AM NOT NECESSARILY I KNOW
IT’S BECAUSE $50 BILLION HAS NOW
BEEN LEVIED BUT ALSO WHAT
HAPPENED?
HE BROUGHT ALL OF THE PRIVATE
SECTOR WHICH IS EXACTLY WHERE WE
SHOULD HAVE BEEN TO BE HONEST
EARLIER.
AND I’M A LITTLE DISAPPOINTED IN
THEM AT THIS POINT AND I’M GOING
TO CONTINUE TO TELL THEM THAT
THEY SHOULD HAVE STEPPED UP.
I DEPEND ON THEM.
I PROMOTE CAPITALISM EVERY DAY
BECAUSE I EXPECT MORE FROM THEM.
I’M GLAD THEY ARE HERE NOW.
I THINK THIS IS WHY THE STOCK
MARKET RESPONDED AND I’M
ABSOLUTELY OPTIMISTIC THAT WE
ARE GOING TO START SEEING MORE
TESTS AND START GETTING THIS
UNDER CONTROL.
>> Greg: YOUR POINT, TOO
ACTUALLY GOOD NEWS, DOESN’T
SOUND LIKE IT WHEN YOU SAY IT’S
LASTING LONGER BECAUSE YOU ARE
SPREADING OUT THE BURDEN.
THIS IS A CASE WHERE YOU DON’T
WANT TO RIP THE BAND-AID OFF
BECAUSE YOU AREN’T PREPARED FOR
WHAT’S UNDERNEATH THAT BAND-AID
IF YOU ARE IN THE HOSPITAL.
WHEN THEY SAY IT’S GOING TO BE
OPTIMISTICALLY IF IT’S THREE
MONTHS LONG THAT MEANS THEY HAVE
PUSHED THAT-OIL REFINERY WHAT
DID THEY CALL IT FLATTEN THE
CURVE.
>> Nicole: IT DOES SEEM LIKE WE
ARE ELON GATING THE PROCESS.
FLU TENDS TO BURDEN OUR
HOSPITALS.
ELONGATE THIS SO WE CAN GET OUT
OF FLU SEASON A LITTLE BIT AND
CARE FOR ALL PATIENTS.
WE DON’T WANT TO BE BURDENED AND
MAKE MAKESHIFT HOSPITALS OUT OF
MOTEL ROOMS.
>> Greg: RATION CARE.
>> Nicole: LIKE WE ARE SEEING IN
ITALY WITH LACK OF RESPIRATORS.
>> Juan: MIDTOWN MANHATTAN, MY
FAVORITE RESTAURANT SAYS THEY
ARE CLOSING FOR TWO WEEKS.
YOU GO INTO SOME OF THE RETAIL
STORES.
AND THE STORE OWNERS LOOK LIKE
THEY ARE -- GET GET JUAN, THEY
WERE LYING TO YOU.
I WAS JUST THERE.
THEY --
>> Jesse: YOU HAVE TO HAVE A
RESERVATION.
I WILL TAKE CARE OF IT FOR YOU.
IT’S LIKE YOU GET UP HERE, THERE
IS NO TRAFFIC.
A LOT OF PLACES ARE EMPTY.
THAT’S FINE.
THAT WILL LAST FOR A VERY SHORT
PERIOD OF TIME.
I WANT TO TALK TO YOU ABOUT THE
CDC.
I DIDN’T KNOW.
THIS A LOT OF THE CDC CRITICISM
I BELIEVE WAS JUSTIFIED BECAUSE
THEY WEREN’T RATCHETING UP THESE
TEST KITS, APPARENTLY FAST
ENOUGH.
DR. FAUCI EXPLAINED THAT THE CDC
WAS NOT DESIGNED FOR A
NATIONWIDE TESTING OPERATION.
IT WAS NEVER DESIGNED LIKE THAT.
THOSE SYSTEMS WERE NOT IN PLACE
ANY ANY ADMINISTRATION.
THE FACT THEY WERE ABLE TO DO
THIS WITH THE PRIVATE SEQ. TORE
THATSECTORSPEAKS HOW RESILIENT I
BEEN.
>> Juan: CONCERN IS THEY DIDN’T
ANTICIPATE AND MAKE THE
PREPARATIONS AND I THINK
EVERYBODY AGREES.
THERE WAS A PROBLEM WITH THE
TESTING.
>> Jesse: YOU CAN’T DO IT
OVERNIGHT AND HOPEFULLY THEY
HAVE IT TOGETHER NOW.
>> Juan: THE PRESIDENT SAID
PREVIOUSLY NATIONAL EMERGENCY
UNNECESSARY.
TODAY, HE CHANGED HIS MIND.